mr dapp hasn't looked at you once this  entire trial has he not that i've  noticed no you've looked at him though  many times haven't you yes i have you  know exactly why mr deb won't look back  at you don't you i do he promised you  would never see his eyes again isn't  that true i don't recall if you said  that let's please play plaintiff exhibit  one two two nine cause i'm not you and i  will always be nothing to you no we'll  never see each other again you know  looking at not my eyes you will not see  my eyes again this is after you publicly  accused him of domestic abuse  yes and got my tro and he tells you you  will not see my eyes again doesn't he  yes he does in that recording and he  kept that promise hasn't he as far as i  know he cannot look at me he won't look  at you right mister he can't